And I want to tell you something Sam go
ahead brother in humanity you went you
went to
Umar right man yes Iban far yeah I was
so eagerly waiting for your
confrontation with but you didn't talk
with him yeah can I explain it again
even if you've been following me for two
years I promise I know you explained it
like you didn't wanted to give him
attent uh attention And not so much not
attention.
Not attention. Let me explain it for the
because I'm going back. God willing,
unless the Lord Jesus tells me to come
home because our life is in the hands of
Jesus Christ, our Lord, I can die
tonight. If you go back, pay attention
again, brother, in humanity. And I pray
you'll be my brother in faith because I
love you for the sake of the Lord. I
mean that. Now, go to the video. You'll
see I look at him and say he's playing
to the camera. He's trying to dole me to
his audience. And he played the victim.
Oh, three of you. one of me. I'm not a
debater. And he pretended he didn't know
me. Right. I I I understand that. That's
why I want you to go. I was so happy to
see you with him because I wanted you to
bring out all of these points.
My my brother, I promise you, God
willing, when he's not expecting it, I'm
going to do it and I'm going to have I
already have the camera crew. The guys
already ready. They're waiting. I'm not
going to mention who they are. But
here's the problem.
Doesn't it upset you that even the
Muslims, Sunni Muslims are now exposing
all his lies and mistakes? Have you not
been watching? There is a Muslim on
Twitter. He's a Sunni Muslim. He's
attacking for all the lies and
misinformation. So, isn't it
embarrassing? He will say stuff and then
later he's caught lying and exposed for
being ignorant and twisting things.
Isn't that a disgrace? Isn't that a
shame? What kind of scholar is he when
he's going to say something thinking
he's going to get away with it now it's
recorded and go people go back and
expose him
this is why I want you to go and
confront him about everything you
dislike about Islam friend I want this
even if I liked Islam I still want to be
Muslim because I love Jesus you still
don't get it Islam for me it can be a
beautiful religion let's say Buddhism
Buddhism has a lot of beautiful
principles, a lot of good things. That
doesn't mean I'm going to be Buddhist
because there's no one and nothing more
beautiful than Jesus. Jesus is beauty.
He is beautiful. He is beauty in the
flesh. And once you taste Jesus, there
is no one else to turn to.
I understand everything. The Quran
contradicts Bible and everything
contradicts Jesus. The beautiful Jesus.
Why why I love Allah is because you know
he explained everything like I know he
didn't explain that uh my words were
changed my Bible was changed and stuff
but you know he said Jesus all these
good things about Jesus are sure who can
talk who can talk greatly about Jesus
like he did in his holy book like he
said uh Jesus won't feel any belittle or
anything if he was called Allah's
servant. Okay? Now, well, here let me
let me show you why that's not good
enough. Okay? I say very nice things to
you, but I tell you, you're not the son
of your father and mother.
Whoever your father is, we're not going
to mention his name. You are not the son
of your father because your father has
no son. So, you are a great man, but you
are not his son. Now, what would your
father say to me? And what would you say
to me when I deny that he's your father
and you I deny you're his son? Would you
still respect me even though I say nice
things to you?
Yeah, that's wrong. But say it again.
That's wrong. Exactly. So God says, "I
don't care how many nice things you say
about Jesus. When you deny he's my true
son, I'm his father, you insult me and
him."
Oh. Oh, the light switch went on. You
see? Oh, now you got it.
How unfortunate it is that we cannot
find the Bible. You know that Quran
keeps mentioning
the Bible what? The Bible that is
mentioned in the Quran that the words of
Jesus and stuff we cannot find it in the
real Bible. Uh so you mean when Muhammad
confirmed the Bible, he's confirming a
fake Bible? No, I I I I'm not saying
what happened with the Bible. I don't
know anything. No, I'm asking when
Muhammad went to the Jews and Christians
and he says, "I confirmed what you have,
the scriptures you have." So, they had a
fake Bible. They didn't have the real
one. So, he confirmed the fake Bible.
No, he confirmed the Bible they had.
Okay. But you said that's not the real
Bible. So, why is he confirming a fake
one?
I'm saying the Bible that today because
it does not have the words that are
there about the Bible in the Quran.
Wait, hold on. I'm confused. The Bible
today is translated from the same copies
of manuscripts that the Jews and
Christians had at the time of your
prophet in the time of Jesus and
afterwards. So what are you talking
about? This is this is a problem I find
about my religion. You know it speaks
about Bible but it uh I cannot find the
words that it mentions are there in the
Bible. When I go to read the Bible it
say Jesus says my father my father. He
doesn't say Allah. Exactly. Oh my god.
Then the Bible.
Exactly. But when I watch Utman's
videos, I watch Utman's videos and he he
talks very good against Christians. So I
want Christians to him. Okay, let's go
with you. I talk very good against
Muslims. But you're going to tell me,
"Oh, but they're not scholars, right?"
So notice what you did. Man picks on
Christians who don't know much about the
Bible. Oh, he talks very good. But I
take people Muslims and destroy their
arguments. But you say, "Oh, that's not
fair. They're not scholars." So why do
you think he's very good when he deals
with Christians who don't know much
about the Bible or the Quran, but when I
destroy Muslims? Oh, that's not fair,
Sam. They're not scholars. Come on.
Yeah, I But but Ukman says these are
knowledgeable people in the title of
video.
I'm going to put in the title of my
video, Muslim Sheh Jihad Ysef.
What are you talking
about? A Muslim she gets schooled by Sam
Shimon. You can put anything in the
title of the video. Okay, right now
after the video, you know what I'm going
to say? I'm going to say Sam Shimon
debated to
Mashiach, you and Jihad. See, I can say
anything. Who said those Christians are
scholars? They're apologists who studied
the faith. In fact, from their answers,
you can tell they don't know much about
the Bible, let alone the Quran.
Mhm. I want you to go and meet him.
Like, sure, I will for you. Anything.
If you go like I'm going to be so happy
like everything you dislike and
everything you find contradictory, just
present it in front of him and let him
speak. Don't talk. The problem is that
sh The problem is it's not letting him
speak. He doesn't let you speak. Look
what he does to David Wood. This is why
David Wood's too nice. David wants to
say
something. Shut up, man. Let me get to
the
point. But don't worry, he's not going
to do that to me.
Uh and also you know regardless the
contradictions that I find still why I
believe because Allah gave reasons uh in
the Quran he said Jews and Christians
you know uh especially Christians
obviously you guys uh say Jesus is son
of Allah. Yeah. So Allah said it's it's
above my uh what why is it above?
It's not befitting for me to my son.
Why? Because I'm one. No one can be like
me. Say what? He said I'm one. None is
like me. Okay. So, what does him being
one none like him have to do with not
having a son? No. No one can be like
him. What does that got to do with
having a son? That doesn't make sense
because because no one's like your
father. You're the son of your father,
right?
Yeah. Yeah, but you're not like your
father. What does that got to do with
anything?
But, but see, we are humans. Uh, there
can be another copy of us. It's God.
Okay. So, let's go with what you said.
So, human beings, they can have sons.
But Allah, because he's not human, he
cannot have a son. But the Quran has a
mother. Is the Quran human?
Oh, I know, man. I got you, man.
did this last time too. Okay. So, is the
Quran human because it has a mother?
What's Can you explain to me?
Oh, I know. It says mother of the book.
I It means status.
Okay. So, why can't God be the father to
Jesus and status? Why does it mean that
if God is the father of Jesus, it means
he's like humans? See, you just answered
yourself.
[Music]
Uh you see I the reason why I can't
believe that because I find you know
oneness of God very beautiful and how
Jesus spoke in the Quran you know how
beautifully in surah
Mariam
Mariam says look at him the baby and he
spoke while he was a baby all these
beautiful things I love about him But
the problem I have a problem with it.
You you're saying to me you can't accept
that Jesus is a son of God. Why again?
Yeah. Why?
Because Allah said it's not fitting for
his majesty. And why is it not
befitting? Because he's one. But you
confuse me. If Allah is one, there is
none like him. That's why. Okay. Okay.
If there's none like him and Allah is
one and if he's one he can't have a son
then how can you believe the Quran is
eternal and it's a book and it's not
Allah but there's one Allah explain that
to me these are his words right these
are from him okay but if it's his words
is the Quran Allah
the Quran is a part of Allah not oh good
good it's a part of Allah so a part of
Allah became a book and you can touch it
because the Quran is a kab. So Allah
became a book, a part of him. Oh my god.
No, that's what you said, man. I'm going
by your words.
Look, I I'm not that smart to answer
that kind of question. I'm just giving
you my man. You know, no scholar can
answer. They say they
say it's meaning we don't understand, we
don't know. That was the expression the
came up with, right? according to Allah
it makes sense to Allah we don't know we
don't understand but we affirm it so why
is it when it comes to something you
believe you can't understand you don't
know how to explain it but you still
accept it but when it comes to Jesus
being God's son doesn't make sense to
you because God is one he can't have a
son so why when it comes to Islam things
don't make sense doesn't mean it's not
true comes to Christianity I fear I fear
the words of the Quran you that's the
real reason say it Don't do Okay,
that's the real reason I want people to
hear the real reason. It's because you
believe the Quran is the word of Allah
and you're afraid to say Jesus God's son
because that means you commit shook,
you're going to go to hell. That is that
is where the biggest blasphemy a person
can do against God. See, so your real
reason is you are attached to the Quran
and you have a fear that if the Quran is
true, you're going to go to hell. That's
the real reason. So we pray for you that
God destroys your fear.